but we're going to begin with a very
impassioned prime time speech from
president biden he was speaking outside
philadelphia's independence hall he
called on americans to fight for what he
called the soul of the nation and he
directly accused former president trump
and his supporters of attacking american
democracy a new cbs news poll finds this
and 72 percent of americans now believe
that democracy is in fact under threat a
figure that has remained high since
trump supporters stormed the capitol
last year ed o'keefe was with the
president in philadelphia last night and
joins us this morning ed good morning to
you the president came out swinging last
night
he did gail good morning the president
spoke to a crowd of mostly other
democratic leaders and activists and
mentioned trump or maga
a total of 16 times but white house
aides are dismissing criticism that this
was too political a speech arguing
there's nothing political about sticking
up for american democracy
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our republic
speaking on the grounds of a national
park and flanked by u.s marines the
president took direct aim at his
predecessor and members of the
republican party maggie republicans do
not respect the constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election a cbs news poll finds more
than half of registered republicans
consider themselves part of the maga
movement you can't love your country
only when you win
visiting president biden's hometown of
scranton pennsylvania before the
president spoke house minority leader
kevin mccarthy argued americans are not
better off fact real income
what you take home
after inflation and taxes
is lower now than when joe biden took
office
while mccarthy focused on pocketbook
issues concerns about threats to
american democracy are now a top issue
for voters among those concerns the
influence of money in politics plus
concerns about political violence and
overturning elections earlier thursday
former president donald trump called
into a conservative radio show and vowed
to pardon those who participated in the
deadly attack on the capitol on january
6 2021. i will look very very favorably
about about full pardons
if i decide to run and if i win that's
exactly the kind of thinking the
president said must be rejected they fan
the flames of political violence
that are a threat
to our personal rights
to the pursuit of justice
to the rule of law
to the very soul of this country
all this comes after a federal judge
just handed down the longest sentence
yet against a january 6th rioter former
nypd officer and marine corps veteran
thomas webster was sentenced yesterday
to 10 years in prison after he assaulted
police and used a metal flagpole as a
weapon meantime out on the campaign
trail the keystone state of pennsylvania
remains in focus former president trump
is headed there tomorrow night to hold a
rally with gop candidates for statewide
office and the president's back in
pennsylvania on monday going to
pittsburgh on labor day but he'll also
be stopping in wisconsin
tony feels almost like 20 24 already ed
thank you very much